now the sport of Chess has been in the
spotlight in recent weeks but not for
the reasons that it might want
accusations of cheating have been
swirling around U.S Grand Master Hans
Neiman with Neiman denying that he's
been getting electronic signals to tell
him what moves to make we'll be speaking
to the authority on cheating in chess in
just a moment but first here's a look at
the story so far
when you're at the center of a chess
cheating scandal the security checks are
going to be thorough but as the US
championships got underway this week
Hans Neiman remains tight-lit
I think this game spoke for itself and
showed the chess player that I am and it
also showed that um I'm not going to
back down and I'm going to play my best
chess here regardless of the pressure
that I'm under the accusations come from
the very top of the sport Magnus Carlson
the world's best player first hinted at
Neiman's alleged cheating early last
month that followed a shock defeat to
Neiman that ended his 53 game unbeaten
streak and there there we have it
handshake then Neiman admitted to
cheating in two minor games online when
he was younger but he said he'd play in
the nude to prove he doesn't wear an
electronic device yeah they could
literally tell me the most ridiculous
thing they want me to strip fully naked
I'll do it I don't care because I know I
know that I'm clean and uh I'm willing
to to subject myself you want you want
me to play in a in a in a closed box
with zero electronic transmission I
don't care you know definitely the
Scandal cranked up a level two weeks
later during an online game between the
pair what no
Carlson quitting the game after just one
move Magnus Carlsen just resigned got up
and left switched off his camera
and that's all we know right now
afterwards he accused Neiman directly
for the first time writing on social
media I believe that Neiman has cheated
more and more recently than he has
publicly admitted
this week the website chess.com said it
found Neiman had probably cheated in
more than 100 online games but never in
person but while Neiman's meteoric rise
up the rankings has raised eyebrows
others in the sport have defended him
they say there's been nothing out of the
ordinary and nothing to suggest cheating
pretty decent London and joining me now
is Kenneth Regan he's a professor of
computer science at the University of
Buffalo in the US but he's also a chess
cheating expert who's been looking into
the Neiman case welcome to DW
um can we start with
can we start with um how to cheat in a
chess game tell us
there are various ways that have been
done in over the board chess including
having a hidden camera an earpiece a
computer in a shoe getting signals to a
phone in a pocket the most common way
however though is doesn't require an
accomplice it's just going to some
secluded location such as a bathroom
stall to check the game on one cell
phone because of the sad reality that
these things can play Far stronger than
Carlson or any other human nowadays so
there's clearly a variety of options now
you're known as something of a chess
detective how easy is it to detect
cheating and and to prove it as well
it's very difficult it's a wicked
problem because it is a societal
contingencies and various factors that
can influence the final interpretation
of the probability numbers that I get
what about Neiman I mean we just heard
in that report he offered to play in the
nude just to prove that he's innocent uh
is he clean right so let me clarify
something right away
um my stand is that he has not cheated
and I have no evidence of his cheating
and over-the-board chess nor an online
chess since August 2020 which is the end
date of the allegations and the
chess.com report and the chess.com
reported its Preamble does support these
findings as far as saying it has no
concrete evidence either so it's it's so
in defending him in the time frame of
more recently in the way that most
people have interpreted Magnus Carlson's
words okay understood let's talk about
anti-anti-cheating technology can it
keep up or are cheaters really getting
away with things
on-site Arbiters have been very
effective they caught someone with a
mobile phone in a tournament very
recently uh it's not clear whether the
person had gotten to the stage of being
able to effectively cheat with it the
sinkfield cup used wands as or the U.S
championships currently going on at the
same location
electronic devices there are some limits
on measures one can take in Europe
especially chess tournament venues are
public places and you cannot do RF
jamming there
Kenneth Regan at the University at
Buffalo it's been a pleasure speaking
with you thank you
thank you very much